on se le dise on sait tous déjà demandé
un jour comment on faisait pour devenir
une star
si l'école ne semble pas toujours être
la meilleure formation pour devenir vip
certains s'en sortent plutôt bien petit
conseil de classe de nos amis les people
et on commence avec britney spears
recalé à 8 ans du mickey mouse club
elle décide de retourner en louisiane
pour finir ses études à 14 ans mais elle
jettera l'épongé avant le bac
d'un autre côté à 17 ans elle été disque
d'or un diplôme comme un autre
miss france 2016 est risqué tonnard
quant à elle a décroché un bac
scientifique avec mention bien et
enchaîner cinq ans d'études de dentiste
avant de décrocher sa couronne alors
qu'est ce qu'on dit sur les miss
bruno mars de son côté devient à 6 ans
le plus jeune sosie d'elvis mais cette
jeune célébrité ne lui fait pas trop
tourner la tête puisqu'il décide de
tenir bon jusqu'au bac avant de
s'envoler vers los angeles et de devenir
la star qu'on connaît avant de devenir
duchesse de sussex meghan markle était
la reine des études avec son double
cursus de relations internationales et
de théâtre à la northwestern university
on lui tire notre chapeau et cyril
hanouna dans tout ça et bien baba a
obtenu un bac scientifique avant de
faire une année de médecine puis de se
réorienter en décrochant à bloc en éco
gestion avant d'entreprendre des études
d'expert comptable bref un parcours
plutôt dark a fait la rentrée après
cepandant mr des as alors c'est vrai
alors non pardon bah voila j'ai du mal
ay croire quand même a alors fait un
petit tour vite fait des diplômes mon
avis ça va aller vite alors laï yu
ouais bah moi j'étais l'enfant d'une
star et je me suis pas super raconter ou
autre mais voilà un père magloire quand
ils et elles et agissez bac +2 de quoi
combler encore un deug d'anglais ça
n'existe plus aujourd'hui d'un deug
d'anglais
d'ailleurs il en reste une ça vous en
coûtera servait à rien ils ont arrêté le
3 févr alors moi j'ai eu un bac avec
mention ensuite abattu et bien oui
et ensuite
une licence de communication et
journalisme magali berda contrat m'ont
fait penser à un terme à la même de 10 à
la manne des diplômes
oui j'ai eu un alors j'ai eu en effet si
le bac avec mention le permis en
comptant 14 après j'ai eu un deug de
droit après j'ai fait un dut gestion
entreprises et ensuite j'ai eu ma carte
professionnelle d'assurance ou s'assure
wmax england un acheteur de
l'information le communiqué c'est un
match sans réaliser dans les médias et
la médiatisation des jeux monsieur qui
confond prestige et prodige maintenant
comme les gâteaux sont les médias comme
pour moi j'ai fait j'ai passé mon bac et
après j'avais que une obsession c'était
partir je voulais quitter la france pour
l'italie d'apprendre les langues et dont
l'album t'as vu en fait elle voulait
rencontrer des italiennes 80 et rapide
alors on y va à peu près les mêmes
diplômes que vous je pense alors moi
j'ai un bac b avec mention assez bien et
j'ai fait deux ans à la sorbonne en
économie et j'ai fait deux ans et voilà
je suis passé comme ça mais c'est à dire
bonjour voila j'ai parce que j'ai eu ma
première année puis lehman et je me suis
barré pour monter une entreprise de
livraison de repas des pizzas c'est vrai
ça qui a déposé le bilan je commençais
tout de suite bien j'aime bien ma
carrière
alors oui mais oui je faisais de blindés
de diplôme bac elle vraiment littérature
dingue et licence d'anglais llc e école
de journalisme
[Musique]
j'ai un bts force de vente
on m'a dit il faut quitter l'éducation
nationale j'ai pas le choix et philippe
ben moi je t'ai le pack de la vie quoi
eh ben c'est tout bon
[Applaudissements]